est en train de prendre la parole je
vous propose d'écouter le président
ce que nous avons observé là ce sont des
traîtres
ce sont des ambitions personnelles qui
ont conduit à la trahison à la trahison
de son pays et de son peuple le peuple
car soutenu nos forces armées les
peuples qui a soutenu nos soldats et les
soldats Wagner ont combattu alors côté
ils ont libéré
et ils ont donné leur vie pour la
nouvelle Russie nouveau Russia mais il y
a des traîtres qui ont essayé
d'organiser une mutinerie qui pousse les
gens à tuer leur frère donc il les
pousse à une défaite et une capitulation
je répète toute mutinerie intérieure
c'est une menace mortelle pour notre
état pour notre nation c'est un coup
porté contre notre pays et notre peuple
et nos actions pour défendre notre
patrie seront très sévères tous ceux qui
sont devenus traître qui ont préparé
cette mutinerie armée
au vent être puni
ils vont répondre devant la loi et
devant notre peuple
armées et d'autres
autorités publiques ont réussi
les ordres et on a des mesures en
conséquence qui sont introduites
actuellement en Moscou et dans d'autres
grandes villes nous allons entreprendre
des mesures
décisives dans la ville de Rostov sur le
don la situation reste difficile là-bas
parce que les
institutions de gouvernance restent
bloquée
en tant que citoyen russe et le
commandant en chef des armées je vais
tout faire pour défendre notre pays pour
protéger l'ordre constitutionnel pour
protéger la liberté et la sécurité du
peuple ceux qui ont préparé cette
mutinerie armée qui ont retourné les
armes contre leur frère d'armes ont
trahi le pays ils vont répondre pour
cela et ceux qui essayent d'appeler
d'autres personnes je les préviens je
pense que ces personnes doivent faire le
bon choix ils doivent arrêter à
participer dans ce crime et je suis sûr
que nous allons protéger nous allons
regarder ce qui est sacré pour nous avec
notre patrie nous allons traverser
toutes les épreuves et nous allons
devenir encore plus fort